the Joe Rogan experience when you first
started working on for the with the the
Mexican government with this it wasn't
like it is now it was so what you give
everybody just a rundown of how it went
down so I went to I went to work for her
state government down in Mexico in Baja
specifically and this was and this was
2004 right right before the start of the
official start of the kick off of the
drug war as a take off the kick off but
there was you know that the official
start was when Felipe Calderon came into
office said you know what gloves off
gonna go after the organized crime right
we're gonna send the military into into
this onto the streets and they're gonna
head up spear head operations against
the cartels but before that things were
happening still you know Sinaloa cartel
was growing there was a rift between the
Sinaloa cartel and Tijuana cartel a
fragmentation cartel heads were being
killed and one cartel 203 all this
fragmentation and then you know in they
basically militarized the war on drugs
with Calderon came in militarized war on
drugs immediately you start seeing that
drug drug enforcement efforts were being
put towards a single or a group of
cartel groups but not the month but not
a major one like Sinaloa cartel so you
start seeing how they were basically
taking sides they were breaking up the
competition that's what you would gather
from the making it look like progress
yeah and and also old chapel has been
built up into this mythical figure like
he was the head of the Sinaloa cartel is
the main guy that's not true at all he
was an operator for the Sinaloa cartel
but not the main operator you know
there's different theories and and and
and about who is actually who was
actually in charge or the brain was
behind the whole operation when you say
Sinaloa cartel is not one group it's
several it's a federation of several
criminal groups enterprises uniting and
working in conjunction to put drugs into
the into the United States well one of
the things they did was put drugs in the
United States you do a lot of things but
that's one of the things they do
so you know certain people sure there's
a lot of people out there that theorized
that my Oh Sam Botta which is El Chapo's
compadre who is still out there is the
actual head of the Sinaloa cartel has
been since a start but you see how some
of these people become celebrities and
as soon as somebody becomes a celebrity
like el chapo who escaped from custody a
few times you know under you know pretty
interesting situating The Situation's
now the government has a celebrity that
can go after it so they can point that
guy that guy's a bad guy right so that
you saw a lot of that a lot of
theatrically attrex around him as far as
him being the head of whatever you know
group or operation was but at the same
time you started seeing you know the DEA
and and in the US government can
decorating and putting all these awards
on a guy like Luna who was the guy that
got arrested recently it was head of
security down in Mexico and now all of a
sudden he's no no he's not you know he
was recognized by the US government as
being a player for the good guys and now
he's arrested so you start seeing all
these you know different interests
different political political kind of
movements around the drug war and what
that turned into and you know what you
don't know what they think right each
and each also each US administration has
changed the way they do things and when
it comes to the drug war and also
benefits certain groups down there so
you know who knows realistic [ __ ] yeah
it's just you know I went to Chichen
itzá I think in 2002
maybe 2003 somewhere around the that
time and there was no concern yeah yeah
it's a different time yeah that's but
that's 16 17 years ago that's so recent
in terms of like human history yeah that
a region changes so radically so quickly
well it's it's there's a lot of things
happening you know there's a lot of
interest China has a lot of interest in
Mexico and you go back and you see
something like these
sorry you see things like the the whole
house um armed groups started popping up
in Mexico in the Michoacan area fighting
back against the cartels the the whole
it was like series like a documentary on
them the the autodefense as they would
they would call basically like vigilante
groups and then you later on you realize
that they were all fighting for
basically protecting or kink or working
around security for illegal Chinese or
Myer mining in the area whoa
yeah it's all it was all about Chinese
ore mining iron ore mining illegal
Chinese or mine so the Chinese or miners
they just made a deal yeah and then you
know that's we can get in on it so let's
arm all these guys and we're protecting
our communities but they're oh it was a
lot of well not not all of them but a
lot of there was a lot of shady stuff
going on in the region and when it comes
to that now you see things like that
stuff that's going on in Sonora and
there's a lot of lithium there that's
pretty valuable thing you know Sonora is
a place that a lot of hunters go yeah
Sonora has these big hunting ranches and
it's like it's famous for giant mule
deer yeah yeah yeah it's a I've been up
out there hunting myself and it's a it's
a beautiful it's a beautiful part of
Mexico but that seems like a sketchy
spot to but its venturing its to it's
perfect because it it's perfect with
them because of rule so there's nobody
around but if you were like a guy from
Texas want to drive your truck down
there it's a little hunting I mean not
my recommendation is this if you have a
4x4 don't don't take it down there take
a [ __ ] you go we do have the largest
population of American citizens living
outside of the country in Mexico for
some reason so really yeah in all
throughout Mexico yeah I mean all
throughout Mexico this one down there
well a lot of people like Cabo
people love Mexican food yeah yeah you
know there's there is there's a certain
chaotic freedom in Mexico which out you
know I've cut being some a child of
Mexico and then moving up here and
seeing you guys talk about freedom and
not that but but there's there sir that
the I get the draw you know and some of
these communities down there pretty safe
but some are you know they're safe until
they're not safe and safe until they
until they all of a sudden you're in the
middle of a someplace that is going to
be disputed which is I think is
something along one is what happened to
some of these Mormon communities down
there
mmm you know you're on your you're in
the middle of your community and your
movements are in the middle of our route
can you please get out of the way
[Applause]